are your kids aware that their dad is
famous do they do they get that oh
you're a celebrity or they're somewhat
but they don't they just don't care at
all which is good yeah yeah it's good
it's fine I mean we recently they got an
example of my star wattage cuz I brought
them to see a Taylor Swift concert and
it was really fun I mean it's a great
show and and she would she was nice
enough to like have us backstage and say
hello beforehand before the show you she
intimidates whiffed invited you
backstage yeah if we were in this like
little room and she comes to super
classy and sweetened yeah comes and
talks to the children and and it was
this small room but also in the room
were Chris Rock and his daughter
daughters and Matt LeBlanc and his
daughter and and then there was just
like this really great looking dude and
his buddy like it was a small room just
a few people and do you know about this
thing at Taylor Swift concerts where
every night she like bring or some night
she brings out famous people I've heard
about this she'll say hey and then she
brings out a famous person yes she just
says hey hey and then famous people
flood this yeah so we're getting ready
to leave this little room and go see the
show and and I say hello to Chris Rock
and and he just says you can go on stage
and and I was like no no I'm not like in
the famous realm to to go on I'm not
that type he's like no you got to go on
stage man right I was like no I'm what
do you want me to there didn't ask me oh
my god don't ask if I can go on stage so
what Rose let you in an embarrassing
position yes so I'm like no I'm not I'm
gonna watch no so we're watching the
show and that point in the concert comes
and Taylor Swift says ladies and
gentlemen Chris Rock and Chris Rock
comes out and everyone applauds and it
makes sense I'm like yes I do not belong
on a stage with Chris were like he's you
know Chris Rock this makes perfect sense
and then and then taylor swift's says
and also ladies and gentlemen matt
LeBlanc and matt LeBlanc comes out I'm
like yeah no this makes sense to MATLAB
like of course he's on friends and you
think deal totally successful guy I'm
like yes this makes sense and I am now
ready to continue with the concert right
but then but then she she says and also
ladies and gentlemen you must have been
like excited yeah yeah yeah
the this guy that was in one of my
videos is here and the the great-looking
guy from backstage comes out I'm like
okay well now this is kind of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yes yeah I think my kids were kind of
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]